Thanksgiving for my family used to be a big to-do and...
...you know, as probably everyone else's does whenever grandparents pass away,...
...it kind of becomes on your parent's shoulders, and we really don't do any big traditions.
It was last year or the year before, my sister and I went and volunteered at a shelter and ordered pizza afterwards.
So, we just kind of do whatever, and football is definitely a big part of that,...
...and the parade is definitely a big part of that,...
...and it's just all about being with some people that you love.
What are your plans for Thanksgiving this year?
I don't know yet, that's too far away.
I'm just right here tonight, and that's all I know.
I'm making my own traditions right now; I'm hosting Thanksgiving for the first time.
I've just had to deal with the classic Thanksgiving conundrum of...
...there's too many people coming for this sized turkey I can fit in my oven,...
...so I've decided to make one turkey the traditional way and deep-fry it.
Turkeys shrink, you know that right?
They shrink.
Yeah, but the pan doesn't.
Okay, but I'm just saying, just be aware that they shrink.
That's what I'm gonna do.
Okay, oh yeah, okay, good.
I'm gonna be with my family, and we're all gonna cook together,...
...and I'm super excited about it.
There's actually nothing that I love more than getting together with my family around a dinner table...
...because that's sort of what we're best at.
Canadian, we've had Canadian Thanksgiving,...
...but I mean, it's all about food isn't it, really, so and you know, giving thanks of course,...
...but food seems to be the number one thing we do at my house.
So, it's like three days all towards this like 30-minute meal.
My mom always says that "It takes so long to make it" and then we eat it in two seconds,...
..and we told her she's not allowed to say that anymore, so yeah, that's our tradition.